several years ago I came here to iron
head studios in Los Angeles these guys
make some of the iconic superhero
costumes you've come to know and love
and I came to them because I asked them
to design me a superhero costume I
premiered it at comic-con people loved
it the next year I had a superhero
vehicle name and that delighted everyone
but something's been missing so I've
returned to iron head studio to design a
suit for an enemy an ultimate adversary
someone vile and evil and the opposite
of me in every single way ladies and
gentlemen
miss Kristin Shaw okay
first of all thank you for agreeing to
do this second of all I'm not super I'm
not sure that you this is the right
energy from my nemesis you you are evil
evil incarnate you have to hate Conan
O'Brien oh hey
I don't know I just feel like I could
find that right away
in here with no self-esteem I could
invest badly I don't have as much as you
think would you invest in theme
restaurants that's a good Ebola that's
Fanta yes let's hold for applause great
and then great is this a bulge a
prominent bulge yeah I'm sorry that you
have to deal with having a penis even a
superhero costume can't make it go away
you have hostility towards the penis I'm
just think you're getting your way for
fights and stuff she hasn't removed
I'm just saying okay is this a kind of
look that you're going for
obviously the female version of this I
mean I definitely want good shoes I see
some of these super hero female costumes
wearing heels yes stop it it's so dumb
what about the fact that there's a lot
of superhero costumes that are clearly
all about being sexy yeah oops
I'm wearing a bulletproof bikini my
thong is made of kryptonite well first
of all what are you doing here with the
male version this is a fairly accurate
representation of my body me I want to
be able to fight I want to be able to
run and I don't need people staring at
my tits unless they stare at them too
long and then I can take them off
foods are so powerful I mean they feed
the human population this just had a
baby I'm pretty proud of where it's at
now but I don't I don't need that I
don't need to reveal this abandoned baby
house your body is an abandoned baby
house the magneto helmet oh look at this
is this what Cate Blanchett wore in for
Ragnarok does a line from the movie
probably probably she's looking for Thor
you're the basement so what do you think
of this is my face that they duplicated
here at Ironhead studios this is an
exact duplicate of Arnold Schwarzenegger
head I think this is a role where he's
getting his master's degree or my
diploma
[Music]
would guess what do you need to know to
design a supervillain costume for
Kristen Schaal um just need to know what
your powers will be oh I think they
should control the applause because I
think as a villain that would really
hurt you scepter you know maybe a
scepter that can detect insecurities
maybe cooling biggest insecurity got it
I can tell you the one thing that I love
about my costume is I have no ass yeah
so tell him your breast idea oh yeah
someone's like staring at my boobs - I'm
like oh you like these and then I rip
them off and so wait so if people if a
guy's looking at your breasts too long
you kill him I can use them to defend
myself because okay man the equivalent
plenty of times I'm in a social
situation I'm like take a picture you
know it'll last longer
you know the hand it happened once
sensitive issue high heels don't want
them I think they're detrimental to
women in society do not put them on my
superhero lady's for like ceremonial
scenes maybe you have heels but unless
it's a really nice occasion
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
we meet again look well what are you
doing on my show so this is my show now
with my crowd
[Applause]
from Bob's Burgers and billeted face the
music coming soon
applause for someone other than me
killing me and what's this
ooh my scepter it's detecting daddy
issues from the scepter never lies Conan
and Andy Richter are you staring at
I was just standing here well if you
like them so much why don't you take a
closer look what
[Applause]
[Music]
I have a great show
[Applause]
you